scp-682 versus scp-1915  could the hard-to-destroy reptile  finally be minimized by an accountant  that's anomalously attached to the  status quo  scp-1915 is a man who has the anomalous  effect of transforming everything around  him to suit his own perception of the  status quo as such he doesn't even know  he's contained he thinks the site is an  office where he just happens to work  when  scp-1915 was sent in to file some tax  papers in an office that just so  happened to be 682's containment chamber  the room in 682 itself began to  gradually transform it became a komodo  dragon then an iguana then a newt then a  goldfish and then it died sadly this  didn't last for long when scp-1915 left  scp-682 went back to normal however he  did make a point of describing the whole  situation as humiliating